this week you've been watching the House
of Representatives try and fail to elect
a new house Speaker you've probably seen
a lot of house clerk Cheryl Johnson
first let me express my deep
appreciation the appreciation of
everybody in this room for the work
you're doing Madam Clark
[Applause]
and her team have been leading the house
through this tumultuous time while no
one else is in charge Ed O'Keefe has
spoken to those who know both the job
and the woman who's making history
the house will be in order you've seen
them in action this week front and
center three women taking control of the
house chamber and keeping members in
line
the clerk would ask all members elect to
abide by the established decorum as the
house tries and tries to elect a new
speaker a speaker has not been elected a
speaker has not been elected a speaker
has not been elected it's the first time
in 100 years the house has struggled to
elect a speaker and until it does there
are no rules that means the house clerk
appointed by the previous speaker stays
on and is in charge congratulations
Cheryl Johnson has had the job since
2019 and then House minority leader
Kevin McCarthy said this about the role
without the clerk Congress could not
fulfill its obligation to the American
people
she's the 36th house clerk the fourth
woman and the second black woman in the
role and she's been on the job over the
course of two impeachments the January 6
Insurrection and now this she can
certainly handle that gaffle former
Missouri Congressman William Lacy clay
has known Johnson for more than four
decades and spoke to her Wednesday she
uh gave me all of the confidence in the
world that she was up for the task an
equally tricky job is being handled by
Susan Cole and Tyles they're reading
clerks whose role ranges from the
mundane russianthaler
McCarthy to the historic Donald John
Trump president of the United States is
impeached it's a job Paul Hayes held for
nearly two decades you really had to
have a strong loud voice hey says given
how often they're on TV clerks do gain
some notoriety the only time he ever
rehearsed his lines was during the
impeachment of Bill Clinton that William
Jefferson Clinton president of the
United States is impeached I knew there
would be a lot of people watching that
and I didn't want to trip over any of
the
legal terms and that's a dynamic that
clay says Johnson as current head of the
house until someone fills that chair
now knows about she certainly does but
to us she's still Cheryl Johnson uh that
that little girl that came to Washington
DC from Louisiana
uh and has made a quite a name for
herself
perhaps there's no surprise Paul Hayes
told us that if you want to be a reading
clerk you want to be the house clerk
you've got to know all 435 people
serving in the house first name last
name how to pronounce it and what state
they're from he says they practice with
4x6 cards with their photos on them and
quiz each other at the beginning of a
new Congress should also point out
Cheryl Johnson knows this is probably
one of her last official duties because
every time a new speaker is elected they
hire their own house Clerk guys wow well
I kind of have a workaround on that
subject Ed you know she's doing such a
great job as Clerk and by the way this
is my favorite piece of the morning but
she's done such a great job as clerican
since speaker of the house does not need
to be a member of the house is there a
movement maybe to draft Cheryl as
Speaker
that would be totally within the bounds
of the rules of the house it could
happen I mean anyone that this is the
crazy thing that people have learned
this week this has been a living
breathing civics lesson you don't have
to be an elected member of the House in
order to serve a speaker uh so yeah
maybe maybe that is all right real quick
Ed do you want to be speaker yes or no
yes he does no no all right with you
guys all right well we'll be right back